this is a painting called Palisades it
shows what once used to live up along
the Hudson River North of New York City
actually built it to help fund a new
park in Guatemala if you and I were to
take a walk through that site right now
we would see some of these plants and
animals but a lot of them would be
missing and to be honest
we wouldn't notice gradual change is
really hard to notice over
time my artistic practice is an
investigation into Humanity's
relationship with nature both what we
have but also what we've lost a painting
like this one called underst Story
begins with a rubric and a database not
with drawings the rubric is the rule of
the painting for this one it is these
are new species and the database space
is built out of a sampling of plants and
animals that fit that rubric it took me
about 4 months of research probably two
or three months of drawing and another
six months of painting to complete under
story most of my complicated complex
paintings take roughly a year on
average these works are my form of
activism when I want to research a bird
I go to a natural history museum and
this is exactly what I
it is a box of specimens or also called
study skins this happens to be a bird
called Paradise parats they used to live
in Australia they are now
extinct specimens have an amazing value
they
are they are two things one they are a
genetic library of traits and at the
same time they carry within their their
feathers and their skin and their scales
a lot lot of environmental data that we
can use when I check out the specimen I
do drawings of it I do color studies of
it I do measurements I take my own
measurements and photographs and I do
all this work because I really want to
be able to depict them accurately and I
want them to be remembered correctly and
as if they are living not just a dried
skin this painting is called canopy and
it is an exploration of species that
have just been discovered every single
living thing you see in it every little
Moss every insect each and everything is
new to Western science I say new to
Western science because it is certainly
not just evolved and it is not new to
the people who live with it they
probably have their own name for it but
it is new to Western
science that newness can carry some risk
there are collectors who love to have a
new species I call this painting trade
because it is about Black Market trade
and Wildlife each of these things is
taken out of Nature and sold somewhere
either legally or not legally both
novelty and Rarity have this awful way
of driving prices straight up there are
plenty of regulations about the sale of
wildlife there's lots of protections and
legal Protections in place but they just
are inefficient because there is such a
drive for wildlife purchase imagine all
of the wild places there are in the
world the million
Acres all of the markets in the world
all of the dark web they're just never
enough boots on the ground to save
wildlife uh it's a big drain on all of
nature Humanity has a way of taking what
we want and what we need but we have
never really
learned or Gotten Good at putting it
back we're like kids or toddlers maybe
this painting called back is about our
hope that nature is
resilient everything in this painting
falls into one of two categories it was
either thought
extinct and then refound by pure luck or
very hard work or it was on the very
brink of Extinction and was hauled back
with some sometimes pretty extensive uh
interventions so on the upper right
there's a marous Kestrel it's a white
bird it went down to actually Four
individual birds it took an amazing
amount of effort on the part of a
handful of people really to get it to
breed again
these were not so lucky everything in
this painting is extinct every grass
every egg represents a bird that's
extinct I don't mean that they're
extinct just here or there they're
really gone from the world you may be
able to tell that I studied the Dutch
still life Masters that was very much on
purpose and I did it because some of
their paintings are between 4 and 500
years old now why are they still here
they're really beautiful that's a great
kind of
insurance they and they also were made
in very very well that just the
materialism is really strong so I've
borrowed a bunch of their techniques
most of their materials and I marry that
with modern science so that I can share
with future Generations some of our
understanding of what's happening to our
biodiversity right now like what's
what's struggling what's thriving what's
uh
doomed It's Kind there the paintings are
kind of like an environmental snapshot a
a picture in time or maybe better like a
message in a
bottle with luck these paintings can
talk to the Future this is a detail from
Gone on your left there's a bird that I
showed you as a specimen the paradise
parrot from Australia gone in the middle
is a passenger pigeon which is extinct
despite the fact that there were
Millions upon millions of them they used
to darken the Skies of this part of
America the Midwest the yelloe headed
bird on the right is a Carolina Parakeet
that used to rocketle fill the Skies of
the southeast of the US this was the
first painting I did of extinct species
so it's kind of gone one but I really
really don't want to have to paint gone
2 3 4 or five when I started started
college I thought we were in the middle
of an environmental crisis and we
were oton thought we were in the middle
of a crisis an environmental crisis in
the
1840s I don't think either he or I could
have possibly imagined the amount of
cumulative destruction of nature we
would see within our lifetime within
each of our lifetimes the depth of our
disruption of nature is so extensive now
so Global that we are of course
affecting the systems that govern the
water the weather the soil the oceans
the climate all of them these are the
very systems that we rely on for our
survival and that nature relies on for
its survival I think of my paintings as
alarm clocks in a way they are reminders
of what's at stake the only real problem
is we keep pushing this news button I
plan to keep documenting in paint
biodiversity that's at risk making a
record of it and advocating for
biodiversity as I can but what's
probably more important is what is the
next message that we that gets carried
through these paintings into the
future it's Humanity collectively that
will decide that
message you know I've thought it could
be well too bad these are these are the
ghosts these are what we lost but it
would be much better if that message was
this was the moment we started to take
action where we really tried to save
life on this planet including our
own thank
you thank you